INTERFERENCE.
>> Tucker: THE GREAT
MARK STEYN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PUSHING LEFT-WING POLITICS, HE
TOUTS HIMSELF AS A SOCIALLY
CONSCIOUS SPORTS LEAGUE BUT
NEITHER ONE DARES CRITICIZE A
MASTERS IN CHINA AND THEY DON'T
WANT ANYBODY DOING ITS OTHER
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO LOSE
MONEY.
DENNIS RODMAN 15 NBA
CHAMPIONSHIPS, BUT AFTER LEAVING
THE NBA, HE BECOMES A INFORMAL
DIPLOMATS.
HE'S BEFRIENDED THE COUNTRY'S
DICTATOR.
HE SPOKE WITH RODMAN HERE'S HOW
IT WENT.
>> SO, WHEN YOU SEE
LeBRON JAMES AND NOT JUST
LeBRON JAMES BUT NBA PLAYERS
AND COACHES UNWILLING TO TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT THE CHINESE
DICTATORSHIP, WHAT'S YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> I LOOK AT IT -- I THINK THAT
NBA IS A GREAT SPORT AROUND THE
WORLD.
I THINK THE NBA PLAYERS HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO DO ONE THING AND
TO PLAY SPORTS.
I THINK -- WHEN YOU PUT POLITICS
WITH SPORTS, IT DOESN'T MIX.
RIGHTS, I THINK THAT IN FACT,
WHEN HE PUT POLITICS AND SPORTS
IT SEEMS TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
TWIST ON THE GAME OF THE SPORTS
WORLD, AND TO BASKETBALL IS A
VERY, VERY UNIVERSAL SPORT.
IT SPEAKS VOLUMES AROUND THE
WORLD.
THE PLAYERS IN THE NBA HAD NO
INFORMANTS ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN CHINA AND HONG KONG.
I THINK IT WAS MISINFORMED OR
THEY WASN'T MOVED IT TO THEM AND
THEY WAS TAKEN PLACE RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: I GET IT, BUT THEY
HAVE GOOGLE AND SOME OF THESE
GUYS -- LeBRON JAMES IS SMART.
NO ONE THINK SHE'S DOWN.
IT LeBRON JAMES -- HE SPENT YEAS
CRITIQUING AMERICAN POLITICS, NO
PROBLEM ATTACKING THE GOVERNMENT
HERE BUT IF ANYBODY ATTACKS THE
GOVERNMENT THERE SHOULD BE
PUNISHED?
HE SAID THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> THE CULTURE AND HONG KONG AND
THEN CHINA IS VERY, VERY GREAT A
GREAT COUNTRY.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
THE FACTS ABOUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
IT'S A FORCE OF CULTURE AND
CHINA OF HONG KONG HONG KONG.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE OVERNIGHT.
THEY'VE A CERTAIN WAY OF LIVING
AND WAY OF LIVING.
IF THEY PLAY WAS ORTS, IF THEY
UNDERSTAND THE CULTURE OF THE
ASIAN COMMUNITY THERE
VERY LOYAL AND THERE VERY LOYAL
PEOPLE.
THEY SAY YES, THEY MEAN YES.
IF THEY MEAN SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY ON THE CONTEXT THEY TAKE IT
IN THE WRONG -- THEY TAKE IT IN
A DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
WAIT A MINUTE, HOLD ON.
>> Tucker: OKAY, BUT WHAT IF
YOU HAD A COUNTRY THAT WAS
TAKING PEOPLE -- MUSLIMS IN THIS
CASE, AND PUTTING THEM IN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS OR A COUNTRY
THAT WAS EXECUTING ANYBODY WHO
DISAGREED WITH THE GOVERNMENT
AND SELLING THEIR ORGANS.
IF YOU'RE AMERICAN'S ESSAY, I
KNOW IT'S A DIFFERENT CULTURE
BUT IT'S KIND OF DISGUSTING.
>> ADVOCATES DISCUSSING, AND TO
THE PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON, THE
POLITICIANS, I THINK IT'S A
VOICE.
I THINK PEOPLE SPORTS ARE
SPORTS, THAT'S NOT THE CONCERN.
YOU CAN WHAT YOUR OPINION IN
AMERICA BUT WENT TO GOING ACROSS
OVER TO ASIA, CHINA, SINGAPORE,
BASHAN, THE DIFFERENCE, IT'S A
DIFFERENT WAY OF LIVING OVER
THERE.
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL WHAT
YOU SAY.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, I KNOW
THAT'S COME UP WITH A CHINESE
BUT HERE IN AMERICA WE ARE
PROTECTED BY THIS UMBRELLA
CALLED THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
BILL OF RIGHTS AND WE CAN SAY
WHATEVER WE WANT TO.
LeBRON JAMES IT GOES WITH THE
TEAM AND ANYBODY WHO CRITICIZES
CHINA OUGHT TO BE CREDIT KNOW
MIKE PUNISHED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHAT YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> ITS UNDERSTANDING, INVOLVED
IN POLITICS.
I THINK LeBRON JAMES IS A VERY
SMART INDIVIDUAL AND HE'S VERY
CARING ABOUT THE PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD AND ITS CHARITY DOES
AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT IF YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE DON'T KNOW TOO MUCH
ABOUT POLITICS.
I DON'T WANT TO KNOW TOO MUCH
>> Tucker: THEN IT SHOULD
LeBRON JAMES CONTINUE TO
COMMENT ON AMERICAN POLITICS?
>> WE GOT THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
>> >> Tucker: EXCEPT FOR WHEN
THEY CRITICIZE CHINA!
AND LeBRON SAYS YOU HAVE TO BE
PUNISHED FOR THAT.
>> WE HAVE NO RIGHTS AS AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO CRITICIZE CHINA OR ANY
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD IN THAT
SENSE BECAUSE, YOU KNOW WHAT,
CHINA THEY REALLY PRAISED
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY LOVE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
OF HONG KONG LOVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
CHINA, I MEAN, SINGAPORE,
BEIJING, SHANGHAI.
EVERY ASIAN COUNTRY LOVES
AMERICAN PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
SPORTS.
SPORTS ATHLETES UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY LOYAL TO
PEOPLE.
I THINK LeBRON JAMES
UNDERSTANDS YOU KNOW WHAT, WHAT
THE POLITICS BE POLITICS, LET
BASKETBALL PLAYERS BE BASKETBALL
PLAYERS.
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU WOULD
LIVE BY THAT STANDARD TO.
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTOOD A LOT